hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the 1970 Palma de Majorca
inter-zonal
tournament it's Bobby Fischer vs. Oscar
panel before we check out the game we do
have a nice photo challenge so best of
luck to everyone who is the Grand Master
in the photo here again we have a nice
photo by David Lada and to give you a
little hint it is her birthday today and
also her brother won the 2018 bill chess
festival so that should be more than
enough of a hint for you best of luck to
everyone now let's check out the game
like we said it's the final round
Bobby has the white pieces and this is
the shortest game of the entire
tournament very few games are as short
as this game because this game believe
it or not I lasted only one move Bobby
played c4 and it was in this position
that Oscar panel resigned the game this
is not a joke this is actually what
happened in the final round of the 1970
palma de mallorca inter-zonal tournament
now as the story goes the final round
was supposed to happen at 4:00 p.m. on
Saturday but because of religious
reasons Bobby Fischer and Samuel
Reshevsky were allowed to start their
games at 7 p.m. on Saturday
Oscar panel did not really find this ok
he thought that I
it's I don't know it's the final round
you're gonna know the results of the
other rounds so that this should not be
allowed for any reasons but I don't know
it's hard to say is it because of that
because here you have it these are the
standings before the final round so
before the final round
we have Fischer at 17 and a half points
hakuna with a 15 Geller with 14 and half
Larsson with 14 taimanov and Oman with
13 and with 12 and a half points we have
a glitch panel a palooka escape or
dismissal in the making so if you
consider this even if panel was able to
defeat Bobby Fischer with the black
pieces he would go up to 13 and a half
points
which would mean that in an off chance
that time on earth and the woman would
lose their games or perhaps draw their
games and none of the other players that
were also in the 12 and a half
region would winter games then maybe
maybe he would have a chance because
Fischer Huebner Geller and Larson were
safe to reach the candidates as none of
the other players could kick them out
out of the top six but as you know the
top six contenders here qualify for the
candidates tournament and also one
reserved so there was a really very
little chance that panel would actually
qualify for a candidate and as we know
from the final standings of the 1970
palma de mallorca inter-zonal tournament
which we have here you can see that
taimanov and the woman both won their
games in the final round so regardless
even if one beat a Fisher with the black
pieces he would still be on 13 and a
half whereas a time on of and woman
would have 14 points so that's pretty
much it
panel resigned at the game and these are
the final standings
so Bobby Fischer won the tournament
crushing the field you know finishing
the tournament with six consecutive wins
not counting this one this being the
seventh with 18 and a half out of 23 so
15 wins only one loss that the bent
Larsen and seven Ross then bent Larsen
in second place 15 out of 23 F in
gallery in third at 15 out of 23 Robert
Huebner with 15 out of 23 then Mark
Hyman off with 14 others 23 and of
Afghan woman with 14 out of 23 whereas
the seventh player the reserved for the
candidates tournament will be decided in
in tiebreaks between alive portage and
the vasily smyslov so that's basically
it but you know we should definitely
show a game between Bobby Fischer an
Oscar panel so as we've already
mentioned that before this tournament
disturbin was in December of 1970 there
was also a tournament in 1970 in Buenos
Aires did Bobby Fischer played also
Oscar pano played there we also
mentioned that tournament when we talked
about Fischer's game between Enrique
making that making was able to draw his
game against Bobby Fischer in that
tournament so instead of this game that
never happened we're gonna show one game
that did happen also Fischer with the
white pieces also was katana with the
black P
only in the death tournament Bobby
started his game with E for so this is
the game we're gonna show it's also an
excellent game and it's kind of a you
know it doesn't have to mean anything
but we will get to see a game between
fisherman panel where the colors are you
know correct so some of you may not know
this as we mentioned that the board's
l'viv cover was the first world used a
Youth Chess Champion Junior Chess
Champion in 1951 where he won the World
Junior Championship Oscar panel is the
second World Championship the 1953 World
Junior Championship that was held in
Copenhagen was won by Oscar panel so in
this match it's actually Oscar panel who
is already a world champion and aside
from the Palma de Majorca inter-zonal
he also participated in five other intra
zonal tournaments so a very strong
Grandmaster of course but you know
enough enough said let's check it out
so we have E 4 and panel replies with c5
Knight to f3 d6 the French variation of
the Sicilian d3 Fischer opts for the the
closed Sicilian we have knight c6 g3 g6
Bishop g2 Bishop g7 both players
fianchetto their bishops fischer castles
Knight G to e7 rook to e1 and d6 see
three panel castles we have d4 see
captures C captures and d5 now Fischer
pushes e5 but from b7 and now Knight to
c3 so a pretty pretty standard closed
position with a closed Center we have
rook to see it simply continuing
development and here already a very
interesting moment in the game Fischer
has to continue his development of
course you would like to develop his
dark square Bishop connector okay
develop the Queen connect his rooks so
here's a good question would you play
Bishop to g5 here Bishop to f4 here or
Bishop to e3 here
well the the principles say that you
should always you know develop your
pieces as far into your opponent's camp
as possible but going bush up the g5
here although it seems very natural
would actually not be all that great
black would simply kick your Bishop away
you cannot go
here because g5 will trap your bishop so
after you move the bishop then g5 comes
again you would have to move the bishop
Knight f5 is coming and you give black a
better position for no reason so here
instead of Bishop g5 federal goes
immediately for Bishop to f4 and now an
idea such as h6 would be met with h4
preventing g5 so after the bishop to f4
move we have Knight to a5 c4 is a very
nice square for the knight so perhaps
panel would like to use it in the future
rook the c1 and here comes b5 as the b v
square is now guarded by the Bishop b3
Fischer doesn't allow this c4 Square to
become an outpost for his night before
we have Knight to e2 and now Bishop to
b5 Queen to d2 connecting rooks night 8
to c6 we have g4 and now a5 Fischer goes
the knight to g3 with that g4 move he
created a nice square for the knight
Queen to b6 and here comes H for Knights
the b8 we have Bush up to h6 Fischer
wants to trade at the dark square Bishop
Knight to d7 and now Queen to g5 rook
captures on c1 rook captures on c1 and
Bishop captures on h6 you can't capture
on e7 because you're look on c1 will be
hanging so you have to capture on h6
Queen captures on h6 and now rook to c8
panel offers a trade-off of rooks of the
second pair of rooks Fischer applies
rock captures Knight captures and here
we have h5 and already we have a
critical moment in the game of course
Fischer wants to bust open the H file it
will not be dead dangerous as he doesn't
have anymore rooks but Knight to g5 of
course is coming everyone can see that
the the best idea here would play it
would be to play Knight to f8
immediately bring a defender of the h7
square and now after H captures H
captures the knight cannot really come
to g5 as it will not be with tempo this
night is already guarding the h7 square
and the Fisher's f3 Knight would be
forced to stay here to defend the d4
pawn
so after h5 while this night to f8 does
does appear to be the best idea
panel went for Queen to d8 and Queen to
d8 simply does not work here and the
Fisher makes quick work of the position
it's quite quite a beautiful plan I'm
sure you'll enjoy it the first move of
course everyone can see it is Knight to
g5 the thread squink actress on h7
followed by Queen captures on f7 with
checkmate so nice to a fate it seems
like there's it's no you know no big
deal playing Knight to f8 on the
previous move or playing Queen d8 and
only now playing Knight to f8 but it
actually makes a huge difference so I
would like to I would like you to pause
the video here and find the move Fischer
used to beat Oscar panel in the 1971
Osiris tournament I will give you a
couple of seconds you know just the
decide whether you want to do it or not
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations you just found simply
a beautiful move and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show if you
found each captures on g6 you would
still most likely win this game although
this is not the strongest continuation
and not the move I wanted you to find
but it would still be okay for example F
captures Knight captures on h7 Knight
captures Queen captures and g6 with
check King moves and now Queen captures
on e8 on e6 white black would be up a
piece here but white would have much
better position f4 is coming Lea you
would have a huge pawn chain here and
Bishop captures and d5 of course coming
white will win this position but it is
not the move I wanted you to find here
in this position a Fischer played Bishop
to e4 and if you found this move then
you are truly a a great chess player
what's the idea here well the obvious
reply D characters on e4 loses instantly
to Knight captures on e4 and then there
is no defense against Knight to f6 check
whatever move black plays for example
Queenie 7 you get Knight f6 check if you
captured n pawn captures and then you
will get Queen g7 checkmate or if you
don't want to lose the Queen and then
get checkmate is King h8 and then you
get Knight captures Knight capture
screen captures on h7 again with
checkmate
so not much you can do here so after
this Bishop to b4 move
did not capture the bishop rather he
played Queen to e7 so now that the
bishop is on e4 Knight captures on h7 is
deadly
we have Knight captures on h7h captures
on g6 and now F captures on g6 an
interesting reply would have been f5
with the idea okay I'm gonna give up the
material back just to stop the attack
but it doesn't work Knight captures on
f5 is coming and then your queen is
under attack
you have to react to this either move
the Queen and phase G captures on h7
would check with tonight still being an
f5 or captures captures with check and
now your King has to move to h8 King h8
and the now comes bunch of to f7
blocking the King Queens defense of the
night on h7 and there is no defense
against Queen captures on h7 checkmate
so a beautiful idea here so after H
captures ng 6f captors and g6 was played
and now Bishop captures on g6 so what's
the problem here
black is up a piece of why can't he
defend well this is the problem Queen g7
offering a trade simply runs into Bishop
captures on h7 with Czech Queen captures
Queen captures here checking the King
and picking up in the night on c8 Queen
blocks and now Queen captures would
result in okay the pieces are now one
pieces both but Fischer would be up
three points in this position of course
a completely winning position for white
so after Bishop g6 Knight the g5 was
played but now comes Knight to h5 again
it all comes down to this Knight coming
to f6 Knight to f3 check and here comes
King to g2 you always have to be careful
I mean you are winning here but you can
always blender the game with King to h1
then you get Queen to h4 check King
moves and now Queen captures on g4
Knight blocks or you go to h1 and then
you get checkmate at so Knight blocks
and now Knights the g5
blocks any ideas of white checkmating
the black king you are up a piece and
you will win this game is black so after
Knight to f3 King G to attacking the
knight
we have Knight to h4 check again King to
g3 and now Knight captures and here
Fischer doesn't capture back first
he plays Knight to f6 check
we have pink to f7 and here Queen to h7
was played and it was in this position
on move 36 that Oscar panel resigned in
the game why did you resign well of
course he only has one square for the
King that's King to f8 the Knight is
guarding d8 square and now Queen to g8
will be checkmate so although we did not
see a game Fisher versus panel from the
1970 Palma de Majorca inter-zonal
tournament as after c4 now yeah I failed
to mention Oscar panel came to the board
he did not just not show up for the game
he actually came came to to the board at
7 p.m. instead of 4 p.m. and then he
after Fischer he saw c4 on the board on
the board and then he came and resigned
in front of Fischer in person so a small
detail but I'm sure you know you will
you will appreciate it but we did have I
think the the 1970 Buenos Aires
tournament was played in August so three
months difference you know still white
Bobby with white Oscar panel with black
I thought it would be a nice game to
show so I do hope you enjoyed it and
with this we are finishing our series of
the 1970 Palma de Majorca inter-zonal
tournament I do hope you enjoyed it once
again let's see this in the final
standings if you want to check it out
some more
so really crushing the field three and a
half points ahead of everyone else even
though it was not all that important to
win this tournament you just have to
qualify for the top six but Fischer was
relentless he played every game for the
win and that pretty much explains his
his core being three and a half points
ahead of everyone else and yeah that's
it for this Palma de Majorca tournament
we are now heading for the candidates
matches in the candidates matches we are
having Larsen versus Ullman that's all
in the quarterfinals Petrosyan vs Cigna
corner vs. Geller and of course the
match we are focusing on Fisher versus
mark time on of the six-game match will
be it will be a treat I already made one
video from this series so I don't think
I will make that one again I will just
invite you to watch it when you know the
time feels right and then we are gonna
continue with the series I don't know if
I'll start the
in 1971 candidates match series tomorrow
I'm gonna check out some of your
suggestions as always gonna check up on
Leela you know see how she is doing and
everything and then then we can start so
I would like to thank Christopher Tosa
and Dan O'Hanlon for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank y'all
for watching and I will see you soon
with some of your suggestions and of
course continuing the Bobby Fisher story
heading into the 1971 candidates matches
thank you all and I'll see you soon